well as it turns out cobid testing was
the key topic during today's update from
clark county health leaders they say
whether you get tested professionally or
you do it at home it's so important for
our community christian cassidis joining
us now live in studio with what else
they talked about today kristin well
denise today was another reminder about
having the correct mask we're talking
about the n95 and the kn 95 which are
recommended by the cdc for best
protection otherwise doubling up on the
cloth mask is always a good alternative
vaccines boosters and covet testing a
reminder that the covet pandemic isn't
over as the government rollout continues
to provide free covet at home test kits
to americans nevada also duplicating
their own efforts to get governor steve
siselek's nearly 600 thousand test kits
distributed those plans still being
drafted kcs locket with the health
district encourages residents about the
recent testing site launched at both
fiesta henderson and texas station a key
tool they say to monitor the virus you
don't necessarily have to report to us
we're not concerned about that we're
only concerned that you test if you test
positive but you really are infectious
when you when you get positive test
results there we just really want to
make sure that you take an opportunity
to isolate both testing sites can
provide a minimum of 30 thousand tests
per week they say this can help reduce
the strain hospitals are currently
facing as they continue to fight a
staffing shortage and a covet surge
well as for the school district
resources have been provided to help the
school district with contact tracing and
at the end of the meeting the message
was simple get vaccinated and boosted
christian casa is live local now